abone ol
ba
[Alkış]
ba ba ba parçalar Koç Abdullah Gül
Üniversitesi uzay etsin inşallah olur mu
[Müzik]
ne yapıyorsun şimdi bunun sıcak
bir çalışıyoruz Savaş çalışmalarda
dönüldü
uzaklaştığında
ama bir şey yapıyorsun değil mi
Tabii ki yani harbi savaş çıksın diye
bir savaş çalışmaları yapmıyorum Aslında
bunu istiyorum ya da
[Müzik]
bu oyunumuzda güzel olunca
şimdi anne kararmaları da yani o
[Müzik]
çok güzel insanlarla devamsız
etkiler mi
[Müzik]
o
kimse de
yaşın canım adama silahlar silahlar
merak ediyorum savaşla ilgili bir şeyler
öğren öğren Öğren
asıroğlu istediğin için mi
[Müzik]
bir şey doktoru yapalım yapalım cesaret
edemem Babam bir çekim olmamız yapamam
Yapamam Yok
istemiyorum
hiçbir şey
yok ki
[Müzik]
da
yapıştırdık
Ben olsaydım şimdi okumaya başladım
olacağım bilmiyorum Çok
eğlenceli
yok ki
[Müzik]
Bu sabah söyledi programlarda ömürlü
söyledi bana da
[Müzik]
bu ama düşündüğüm gibi olmadı
İlk önce doktora programı teker teker
hepsinin
üstüne tez yazma aşamasında
yazı yazma ya
[Müzik]
ben gördüm orada konuşmaya başladım işte
Türkiye'de sistemine sıkıntılar var mı
[Müzik]
Evet tamam Bu sefer oldu sefer oldu
unutamayacağım bir önce paketi
öyle değilmiş
[Müzik]
ama hemen al
ama
yarın
ama idare etme yine başladı departman
var o da apartmandan kabul alıyorum
şimdi karşılığı bir seçenek var hazır
geldi a a
[Müzik]
O sigarayı 45
kaldır dedi
böyle olunca gittim
olarak yaptım ki
bu
Merhaba
Biz başında
başlıyoruz ne kadar başladı mı
[Müzik]
o erkek şöyle geliyorum o zaman kolay
olsun diyorum ne oluyor
Son dakika
Türkiye dönüyorum
için sıkıntı yok
[Müzik]
bu iş aramaya devam ediyorum
süper şöyle olur mu size de biliyorum
ama Sanayi Nasrettin
Hoca'nın o
Yok canım tamam yani başka bir şey
yapacağım başka bir iş bulacağım
hakkında
okula mı
[Müzik]
Ne
kızıyorsun ya geçeceğim Yani beni
almıştır var Onu çerçevesinde belirlenen
çokyaşar var Bazen şahıs bazen
şanssızlık
tercihler geldik birçok
ve tarçın var bu birçok tacı birçok
farklı çekiliş sonuçları bildir yani
kabul edebilirim olduğunu bilmiyorum son
çıkabilirdi
uzandım daha farklı olurdu
Bye bye
nasıl çok şey
biz elimizden gelenin en iyisini
yapıyorsun
bütün
içinde unutmamamız gereken bir şey var
yok çok farklı yerlerde olurmuş
yolculuk
[Müzik]
normal mi
[Alkış]